Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dansScienceClic,
la relativité générale.
Qu'est ce que la gravitation ?
La gravitation,ou gravité,
est un phénomène fondamental dans l'Univers,
qui tend à unir les objetsentre eux.
Si la pomme tombe au sol,
que la Lune tourne autour de la Terre,
et quela Terre tourne autour du Soleil,
c'est à cause de la gravité qui lie ces objets entre eux,
lesempêchant de trop s'éloigner les uns des autres.
A première vue, on pourrait
penser quela gravitation est une force
qui agit en attirant les objets en fonction de leur masse.
Plus un corps serait massif,
plusil attirerait les autres objets de l'Univers dans sa direction.
Cette représentation de la gravité,comme une force,
permet de comprendre
le comportement des objets lorsqu'ilstombent,
ou encore la façon dont les
planètes orbitent autour du Soleil.
Mais, en réalité, certains indices subtils
indiquent que la gravitation n'est pas vraimentune force.
Par exemple, lorsqu'on observe
un satellite en train de tomber sur Terre,
si la gravité était une force, il devrait tombertout droit
vers le centre de la planète.
Mais quand on fait l’expérience,
on observe que sa trajectoire est très légèrement déviée sur le côté,
dans le sens de rotation de la Terre.
Autreindice, l'orbite de Mercure
change d'orientation au cours du temps,
avec une certaine vitesse.
Si la gravité était une force, on sait prédire avec exactitude
la vitesse à laquelle devraitévoluer cette orbite.
Mais dans les faits,
on observe que l’orbite de Mercure varie au cours du temps
avec une vitesse légèrement différente.
Si l’on s’intéresse à prendre
en compte cespetites subtilités,
on s’aperçoit finalement,
que la nature de la gravitation est toute autre qu'une simple force.
Lacerner nécessite de revoir entièrement notrevision du monde,
de l'univers tout entier, ainsi que de l'espace et du temps.
C’estce qu’on appelle la relativité générale.
Pour se construire, la relativité générale
se basepresque entièrement sur un principe fondateur,
le principe d’équivalence.
Le principed’équivalence postule
que tous les objets tombent de la même façon.
Il dit que la chute
libre n’est pas l’action d’une force,
que ce n’est pas un mouvement
accéléré de l’objet en train detomber,
mais qu’au contraire,
la chute libre est le mouvement naturel des corps.
Lorsque des objetstombent sur Terre,
la situation revient à dire que ces objets sont en fait au repos,
et que c’est enréalité le sol
qui accélère dans leur direction.
Contrairement à notre intuition naïve,
c’est lefait de tomber qui constitue un
mouvement naturel, un mouvement de repos,
tandis que le fait
de rester immobile à la surface de la Terre,
revient en réalité à s’opposer constamment à sachute,
à exercer sans cesse une accélération vers le haut.
C’est d’ailleurs pour cette raison
qu’onne ressent notre poids
qu’au moment de toucher le sol.
Pendant une chute libre,
notre corps suitson mouvement naturel,
et ce n’est qu’au contact du sol qu’on ressent notre poids,
cette actiondans nos pieds qui vient s’opposer à la chute.
En relativité générale,
la gravitation n’est doncplus une force.
On pourrait presque dire que la gravitation n’existe pas,
ou tout du moins, quec’est une illusion.
Si les corps nous donnent l’impression
qu’ils tombent, et qu’ils s’attirent entre eux,
c’est parce qu’ils se déplacent defaçon naturelle, au repos,
mais dans un univers à la géométrie courbée.
Les corps ne s'attirent pas entre eux,
ils ne font que se déplaceren lignes droites,
mais de par leur masse,
ils courbent l'espace-temps autour d'eux,
ce quiinfluence les trajectoires des autres objets.
L'idée la plus importante de la relativitégénérale,
est que tous les corps qui possèdent une masse
déforment l’espace-temps autourd’eux.
Pour comprendre,
si on imagine notre univers comme un immense réseau,
une grilled’espace et de temps,
un objet massif va avoir pour effet
de déformer cet espace-temps autour de lui.
Les notions de distances, de directions,
ou encore d’écoulement du temps,
sont ainsiperturbées, altérées par la présence de l’objet.
De façon naturelle,
un corps va avoir tendanceà se déplacer en ligne droite.
Par exemple, si on lance une pomme
au beau milieu du vide intergalactique,
elle va continuer sa trajectoireen ligne droite,
toujours à la même vitesse.
Maislançons maintenant cette même pomme
à proximitéd’un objet massif, comme la Terre.
Comme elleest très massive,
la Terre déforme l’espaceet le temps autour d'elle.
Les lignes droitessont désormais distordues,
elles se courbent et s’entremêlent en direction de la planète.
Ainsi, quand on lâche la pomme, elle va partiren ligne droite,
mais comme les lignes droites
ont été déformées par la masse de la Terre,
la pomme va progressivement se rapprocher du sol.
C’est cet effet qu’on appelle la gravitation.
Lorsqu’un corps est très massif,
il déformela structure même de l’univers autour de lui,
courbant les lignes droites dans sa direction, et
par conséquent, tous les objets qui l’entourent
vont avoir tendance à suivre
ces lignescourbées, et à se rapprocher de l'objet.
Pour mieux comprendre,
imaginons en parallèleles deux situations suivantes.
D’une part, deux observateurs
se déplacent en lignedroite vers le haut,
à la surface d’un plan,
c’est à dire sur une surface non courbée.
D’autrepart, les deux observateurs
se déplacent en ligne droite en direction du Nord,
mais à lasurface de la Terre,
qui est une sphère, et donc cette fois-ci une surface courbée.
Dans la première situation, pour la surface non courbée,
les deux observateurs vont
se déplacer enligne droite, de manière parallèle.
Ils ne vont de cette façon jamais se rapprocher l’un de l’autre.
Mais dans la deuxième situation,
à la surface dela Terre, en marchant tout droit,
nos deuxobservateurs vont bizarrement finir par se rejoindre,
au moment d’atteindre le pôle Nord.
Bien que chacun d’eux ait marché
parfaitementen ligne droite, un pied devant l'autre,
du fait que la Terre est courbée, et par conséquent
que les lignes droites sont déformées à sa surface,
les deux personnes ont eu l’impression
qu’une force mystérieuse les attirait,
lesobligeant progressivement à se rejoindre.
Avec cet exemple,
on comprend mieux commentle phénomène de gravitation
peut émerger à partir de la courbure de l’espace-temps.
Les objets semblent s’attirer entre eux,
leurs trajectoires semblent se rejoindre progressivement,
mais en réalité ce phénomène
est dû à la courbure des lignes droites,
le long desquelles se déplacent les astres.
Pour illustrer les différents phénomènes
étranges qui apparaissent en relativitégénérale,
intéressons nous à un objetfascinant de l’univers,
le trou noir.
Un trou noir est un objet massif,
dont toutela matière
est principalement concentrée en un seul point.
On appelle ce point central
une singularité gravitationnelle.
A cet endroit précis de l'univers,
le tissud’espace-temps est distordu à l’infini,
et la science moderne ne sait
toujours pas décrirece qui s’y passe.
A proximité de la singularité,
la courbure de l’espace-temps est si intense
quetoutes les lignes droites pointent dans cettedirection.
Ici, aucun objet ne peut espérers’échapper du trou noir.
Même pour un rayon lumineux,
toutes les trajectoires possibles
mènent directement vers la singularité.
Le trou noir n’émet pas de lumière,
etaucune matière ni rayonnement nepeut s’en échapper.
Pour cette raison,
onle voit comme une sphère complètement noire.
A l’extérieur de cette zone de capture,
au delàde cette frontière qu’on appelle son “horizon”,
le trou noir se comporte
à peu près commen’importe quel astre.
Lorsqu’on se trouve à proximité de l’horizon,
il est impossible de rester
en orbite stable autour du trou noir.
La déformation de l’espace-temps est tropprononcée,
ce qui rend les trajectoires des objets chaotiques
et difficiles à prédire à cette distance.
Mais dès lors qu’on setrouve suffisamment loin de l'horizon,
commedans le cas d’une planète ou d’une étoile,
il est possible de graviter
de façon stableautour d’un trou noir,
et un objet passant à proximité sera légèrement dévié,
mais pourratout de même s’échapper de son attraction.
En particulier,
les rayons lumineuxqui proviennent des étoiles lointaines
vont bifurquer
au moment de passer àproximité du trou noir.
Pour cette raison, si on observe le trou noir de face,
on peutvoir une image déformée
des étoiles lointaines,qui se trouvent en arrière plan.
C’est ce qu’onappelle l’effet de lentille gravitationnelle.
Un autre phénomène intéressant
apparaîtlorsque le trou noir tourne sur lui-même.
Dans le cas d’un trou noir en rotationtrès rapide,
celui-ci entraîne légèrement
le tissu de l’espace-temps dans sa rotation.
Un objet qui tombe en direction du trou noir,
parcourant ainsi une ligne droite courbée,
sera légèrement dévié dans le sens derotation de l’astre.
Cet effet très étrange
s’applique d’ailleurs également pour la Terre,
dont la rotation sur elle-même entraîne très
légèrement la chute des corps à sa surface.
Enfin, l’un des phénomènes les plus notables,
estce qu’on appelle
la dilatation gravitationnelle du temps.
Lorsqu’on se trouve à proximité
d’un objet massif comme un trou noir,
les lignes droites que l’on va suivre sont
non seulement déformées dans l’espace,
mais également dans le temps.
L’écoulementdu temps va être altéré,
en fonction de la distance
à laquelle on se trouve d’un objet massif.
A grande distance du trou noir,
là où la courbure
de l'espace temps estnégligeable,
le temps s’écoule à peu près comme n’importe tout ailleurs.
Mais plus on serapproche du trou noir,
plus on va ressentirque le temps s'écoule lentement.
A proximitéde l’horizon du trou noir,
l’espace-temps est tellement déformé
qu’il est possible que
chaque seconde qui s’écoule pour nous,
prenne en réalité une année entière
pour s’écouler, du point de vue d'un observateur lointain.
Dans le cas général,
plus on se trouveà proximité d’une source de gravitation,
c’est à dire d’un objet massif
comme le Soleil ou la Terre,
plus notre temps va s’écouler lentement.
A lasurface de la Terre par exemple,
si on compare les horloges de deux personnes,
l’une se trouvant au pied,
et l’autre au sommet de la Tour Eiffel,
l'horloge de la personne en bas
va tourner légèrement moins vite,
car elle se trouve plus proche du centre de la Terre.
Typiquement,pour chaque année qui s’écoule,
la personne au pied de la tour
aura vieilli d’une microseconde en moins
que la personne au sommet de la tour.
Cet effet de dilatation des durées
est trèssubtil, mais très important.
Sur Terre, il est notamment central
de le prendre en compte lors de la conception des satellites GPS,
de sorte à assurer
lasynchronisation de leurs horloges internes.
Pour résumer,
la relativité générale donne uncadre de compréhension
pour cerner la nature même de ce qu’est la gravitation.
Lorsqu’unobjet massif repose dans l’espace-temps,
il déforme sa géométrie autour de lui,
courbantles lignes droites dans l’espace et dans le temps,
ce qui a pour effet de dévier la
trajectoire des objets environnants,
et de modifier leur perception du temps.
Outre la gravitation,
la relativité généraleentraîne également
une quantité d’autres conséquences étonnantes.
L’une de ces conséquencespar exemple,
est que l'espace-temps ne se déforme pas de façon instantanée.
A la manièred’un tissu que l’on viendrait perturber,
si un objet apparaît de nulle part,
son influence gravitationnelle va mettre un certain temps
pour se propager progressivement à travers l’espace et le temps,
courbant lagéométrie de l’univers
au fur et à mesure de sa progression,
et ce, à la vitesse de la lumière.
Cette particularité entraîne
l’existence des ondesgravitationnelles,
c’est à dire des phénomènes
de distorsion de l’espace et du temps,
qui sepropagent à travers l’univers à la vitessede la lumière.
Ces ondes gravitationnelles,
sontgénérées à des années lumières de la Terre
par des événements cataclysmiques,
par exemple la fusion de deux trous noirs.
Elles viennent nous traverserrégulièrement,
déformant légèrement notre planète
et tout ce qui s’y trouve, sous leur passage.
Enfin, cette idée que notre univers
puisseprésenter une géométrie distordue
pose la question de sa forme à grande échelle,
et incite à de nombreuses imaginations,
comme l’existence possibles de raccourcis
géométriques à travers l’espace et le temps,
encore très spéculatifs à ce jour,
c’est ce qu’on appelle les trous de vers.